on est content qu'il ait mon chéri aussi
tout un symbole en émotions réelles
allie souplesse et raymond alors je me
souviens de ce rendez vous avec toi pour
faire de la radio
j'étais tellement flipper que j'ai été
faire pipi trois fois fit est arrivé et
tu m'as dit t'inquiète pas j'adore tes
cheveux c'est bon c'est signé j'ai pas
pu aller jusqu'au bout de la saison j'ai
arrêté avant la fin à cause des
livraisons tu m'a regardé dans les yeux
et tu m'as dit raymond si tu t'amuses
plus faut partir est athée livraison va
faire tes livraison mais regarde moi
bien sûr la tête de ma mère que je ne
lâche pas je me suis dit bon c'est des
phrases qu'on dit comme ça dans ce
métier là à mon avis la suite tu la
connais je la connais l'amitié
s'installe nos texto on échange ton
envie de me remettre à chaque fois à
l'antenne de pas me lâcher touche pas
mon sport l'an penses quoi
tp mp3 fois trois échecs tu viens me
voir et me dit ça ne marchera jamais
citer pas toi-même les conseils toujours
les conseils la bienveillance malgré nos
désaccords tu cherche toujours à me
protéger tel un grand frère pendant
l'émission mais surtout après démission
alors oui j'ai rencontré des vedettes
j'ai rencontré des chroniqueurs
extraordinaires ici des gens
intelligents que j'avais jamais vu dans
mon monde à moi ça n'existait pas des
gens comme ça kim qui m'apprennent des
choses je t'ai vu parler à des
agriculteurs des ministres des gilets
jaunes déjà en galère à quito faire des
maisons devant moi ça je le voyais à la
télé ça me faisait rien devant moi ça me
faisait pleurer après dans mon boulot
les gens me disaient bravo raymond
continue comme ça à la télé ça motive et
ça motive
pour toutes ces raisons je suis contente
que la vie mais fait croiser ton chemin
je suis fier d'être près de toi je suis
fier d'être ton pote mon cyril hanouna
qui a distrait ma vie je t'aime serré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon frère alors bon ouais t'es pas
prochain franchement mérité suis foutu
de toi tout à l'heure mais décrit très
bien la vérité parce que c'est ça vient
du plat commun ce qui se passe c'est pas
commun de prendre un livreur et lui dire
une fois tu vas faire de la télé le mec
fait de la merde c'est pas y retourner
il fait de la merde et troisième fois tu
vas y arriver quand tu seras toi même et
y avoue c'est vrai la saison a été
longue
je me suis parfois énervé plusieurs fois
j'ai eu des accrochages avec mathieu
mais faut que les gens sachent que c'est
des gens qu'on va pu me tirer dans les
pattes c'est des gens qu'on a pu me
mettre de côté quand même pu ne pas
m'aider à chaque fin d'émission
et quand tu ne sais combien de fois j'ai
voulu me barre et j'ai dit demain jugé
grave d'ailleurs il me barre tous les
textos que j'ai reçu de chacun ne
t'inquiète pas ça va aller c'est comme
ça à la télé voilà je voudrais dire aux
gens quand on parle de famille il ya
ceux qui nous aiment pas et c'est pas
grave continue et pas nous aimer c'est
votre choix et ceux qui nous aiment
mais quand on parle de famille allait
elle est là quoi que vous pensiez elle
est quand même là la famille